hi guys so this is a joint work with
mrs. hisk up key and even is complete so
as Mary just say a certain set up can be
instantiated badly so in this talk in
this work we're gonna do populated time
with your knowledge we don't have to set
up so what is the outline of the talk
first I'm gonna say a little bit about
so first of all I'm gonna go over public
I probably if I was your knowledge and
then I'm gonna talk a little bit about
what it means to use a blockchain as an
assumption for your crypto protocol and
then I'm gonna move on to our
contribution so public event if I will
do don't know it is a they don't know
it's proof that you compute once and
then you can use it for multiple value
fires and typically we associate needs
to public Wi-Fi about zero knowledge it
does not have to be this way but and it
is publicly verifiable because it's just
one method you compute your proof you
send it to the world and everybody will
believe it so will be convinced and as
we say it multiple times it's becoming
more and more important this property
for a blockchain application because
people will post their their proof they
will put it on the blockchain and
everybody can verify that it's that
computation was done correctly has Mary
pointed out so probably if I will do a
knowledge at the moment so we only
require set of assumptions and because
basically it's the same as computing and
no interactive zero knowledge protocol
and we know how to construct them from a
CRS which requires trusted party or you
can do you can mitigate trust using this
update about CRS or using MPC or you can
do a random Oracle and then you have a
heuristic abstraction now the question
is given that we already know that this
block chains exist we are working a
natural question is to to ask is whether
in the in place of a trusted setup can I
use the fact
the blockchain exists to build a
publicly verifiable to your knowledge
protocol so basically instead of using
any setup can I just say well because
Bitcoin exists
I can build a public grave I build your
knowledge block oh right so kind of
leveraging these assumptions which are
already there they already kind of this
seem to hold and this is this question
has been already explored for other
tasks for example fairness for NPC we
know that it's impossible to have
fairness in standard model but if
Bitcoin we can maybe leverage Bitcoin to
to have a fair MPC protocol now before
we we move on on using this blockchain
assumption let's see what it means that
we're gonna use a box in essence alright
so let's say you want to leverage your
the existence of a blockchain to build
your crypto protocol that you don't know
how to build otherwise without trusted
setup so basically what you're actually
doing is you are basically using the
threat model that you were usually using
crypto which is our adversary's point on
your side that's the only thing we
assume about the adversary other things
about the network but mainly it's
polynomial time but then you're also
adding some constraints to your
adversary for example you are taking all
the constraints that are there for the
blockchain assumptions for the boxing
proto for example if you are using a
Bitcoin blockchain you are also saying
that your adversaries point on your time
and does not control the majority of the
power so it's kind of even more
constrained at point on your time if you
are using a proof of state kind of
assumption it was no question superseded
the PPP if you're saying the adversary
is linear time for example
yeah it's even more constraint right so
not only through PT but is also other
things right you're saying why did I put
it in a little box what's that no no if
you are oh yeah sure if you cannot have
definitely it's also creepy
yes yes so then why did I put it in this
box because there are other things that
you're going to take from the blockchain
world for example in the blockchain we
assume that adversaries are adaptive so
players so in adversity can adapt can
corrupt adaptively blockchain players so
one player can be honest today and
tomorrow it might not be this way it is
not necessarily the case that when you
build a crypto protocol you necessarily
prove that this secure against adaptive
corruption but I agree the the choice of
the boxes says it's it's not good all
right so that's kind of what you do if
you are leveraging a blocking assumption
now the question was can I use any sun
block chain assumption to to build a
public verifiable dealer knowledge
protocol and there was an answer this
question was investigating 2017 by Goya
Goya and they show how to build a
non-interactive zero knowledge protocol
from proof of stake what was the idea
well the idea is that well this proof of
stake blockchain exists and what is the
assumptions under a proof of stake
blockchain the assumption and high level
is at any point in time if you look at
the total stake on the blockchain the
majority of it is in the hands of honest
parties that's kind of the underlying
assumption which basically means at any
point in time an adversary cannot make
Forks long Forks high level how can you
leverage the assumption to create an
it's more interactive do you knowledge
proof well you can say well you can
assume that now the simulator controls
the honest party and then just using a
typical FLS paradise your niche is not
nothing but in an interactive WI
protocol where you prove
either X's in L or I computed a long
fork right now in the blockchain
assumption any adversary will not be
able to do this
therefore this niche is sound so
soundness relies on the fact that proof
of steak block chains work and you know
it relies on the fact that you know if
your simulator controls the majority of
the players then your simulator can
knows the witness for the for the longer
the longest the longer for the idea now
let's look at the sound arrest soundness
the proofs unless you assume that your
ethics PPT and does not and you have an
honest majority of steak for dinner
knowledge you assume that the eraser is
TPT and again the majority is honest so
it's in the end the majority of players
is controlled by the simulator but in in
this particular proof so there are two
additional constraints that are needed
for the proof to go through one is that
the general knowledge addresser is not
allowed to corrupt so no adaptive
corruption of blockchain players another
requirement for the journal's proof to
go through is that by the way Ayana
stakeholders who never reveal their key
right so if you have all this if you
have these assumptions then you can
prove that your your scheme is zero
knowledge
so basically what we can see nothing
really it doesn't really match the
threat model that we assumed for the box
chain is slightly more constrained so we
are adding more constraints so what we
do in our work so is the first
contribution we highlight some
subtleties right when that rises when
you want to use a block chain to your
crypto protocol in fact if you're not
careful in matching the threat model of
the block chain assumption that you're
using
then again subtleties can arise and in
fact we show that in a single adversary
playing in the block chain like a
legitimate player could break the zero
knowledge property of I call the GG
needs to refer to the needs of Colin we
are in 2017 and basically in light of
this this kind of leaves open again the
question on whether we can be public
with if I don't know it's just
leveraging some blockchain assumption
yes it's a counter example it's an
attack to the to the zero knowledge
proof to generate security so we show an
ad valid so we're not we're hmm
no we are not actually violating so when
you say to the definition under
construction what you mean
yeah actually no we are not we are with
the within their definition they just
use new look inside the new week but do
they actually look they could say okay
here's a new we take a new we and my
construction is new we have this and
this and the proof is no matter what we
we you take yeah I think maybe you refer
to what type of how do they frame their
blockchain assumption right in fact yeah
in fact no so we are actually following
their definition so we are not yeah and
you'll see is not a super difficult
attack is just we will see in a second
and then maybe we can talk again of what
was the what is the difference between
adversary and obviously playing is a
blockchain user because the blockchain
user can be honest a baktun user a
meaning that the adversary does not have
to be a corrupted blockchain user okay
so in a blockchain setting if you are
let's say you are reminded of a
blockchain
you can be honest following the protocol
you can be dishonest doing your own
things so here I'm just like I don't
in order to do two month this this
attack the adversity does not have to be
dishonest in the blockchain protocol it
does not have to be dishonest the miners
have some choice and they can within the
rules of blockchain blast that choice to
break your knowledge yeah so yeah so
maybe let's go to the attack and then
we'll go back so the adversary is not
doing anything fancy is just using as a
user like you go to the to the post you
go to the bank you enter and you open
your account you are just an out
yourself between between F and B in
distributed just says if there is one
advanced Aries is one but this can be
adaptive there is no consensus and
similar thing holds here no my adversary
no does not have to be adaptive no we'll
see in a second so this kind of leaves
open the question of whether we can do
PV neat from China sometimes we do
propose a construction from a block a
genetic boxing gene assumption that I'm
going to introduce so let's see and and
we prove that
our scheme remains as it should be
proven right it means blockchain remains
zero knowledge even if later the
blockchain collapses so even if later
all the miners will be malicious or the
blockchain protocol is completely
changed the zero knowledge proof so if I
have the strings which is my remains so
in this case my my assumptions going to
be there exist a blockchain that has
this property and I explain block
Bitcoin for example might have this
property Duhamel assumption
exactly exactly that's exactly what we
are trying to advocating this work you
have to use the blockchain of some sort
in such a way that you are using some
property you don't have to worry about
how is this implemented and the
adversarial blockchain is doing you just
have to worry so in terms of this should
be a decouple you're using some
assumptions about the world but you have
to be careful the way you use it right
you don't want to use some specific yes
you're relying the blockchain is
actually exist I'm gonna I'm gonna
define a property and
if there is a book chain that has this
property in the real world then my
scheme is secure I do whatever is this
again is this little bit of something
else which will be analog to Ivan
adversely
it can take messages or things that run
now and co-opt them but it cannot go up
the past is this yeah cannot grab the
past for sure I cannot go back and
change the world you know I cannot go
back and change what happened in the
past
that will be good too I would love it ok
so let's see if I hopefully I answer
some of the questions ok so let's first
look at this attack that we are
suggesting right in order to understand
this attack let's look at this
construction a bit more carefully Eugene
it's so how it works we have this
blockchain is proof of stake what that
means in me that for every block there
is going to be an owner of the block
which is the stake holder that was able
to publish that block and the
stakeholder identified by public keys
and indeed a neat they are going to use
this public key for both the same public
key for both signature an encryption
alright so they are going to prove the
following relation X's in L or I know a
fork of length K where K I'm making it
so in case the parameter of their
assumption right it's a blockchain
assumption with their some parameters
let's call it K there are two parameters
that way let's call it K now the idea is
the following I have a witness for this
relation I'm gonna see I share it with
the waited to be shedding skin and I'm
gonna encrypt each share which key am I
going to use I'm gonna use the keys of
the stakeholders which stakeholders I
again depends on which piece of the
blockchain I'm looking at so I'm gonna
look I'm gonna take a big chunk of the
blockchain and I'm gonna see what are
the the key is used in these blocks and
I'm gonna use those keys to encrypt HP
so each piece is encrypted with a
different key
and then I'm gonna add the new way using
growth for example new way and saying
well these are encryptions I'll correct
encryption under the stakeholders keys
and these are encryptions of shares and
if you reconstruct if you have enough
shares you will reconstruct a witness
that's the scheme now you can see where
things can go wrong here now why am i
encrypting under stakeholder schemes
because it's no soundness proof I want
to say if the extractor knows the
majority of the keys then can extract
the witness and I and then I'm good I
can prove soundness oniy way means
non-interactive witness
indistinguishable in distinguishability
and here we are just saying we add the
proof that proves that the statement
these are encryptions under the stake on
their skis and from this prop you cannot
distinguish which witness was used so
you cannot distinguish even if this is a
witness for X's in L or if it's a
witness for you know watching the
stakeholders often have like signature
keys but you're saying can also use them
so in the in particle in GG in its they
assume that this blockchain works this
is an additional assumption but you know
the same key can be used to sign and
increase which happens actually with the
it's actually it's not a biggest I'm
sure if it's true there are schemes that
have this right so that you can see
these are report on these encryptions
are important for soundness but now you
can see that this creates a problem
because now I have this remember these
proofs we are not going to put this
proof on the blockchain I this proof I'm
gonna give this proof to a wit to a
verifier to a verify around this proof
is in the hand of the verifier
the verifier can hold it for many for
many years and now and again this proves
is just a bunch of encryptions under
stakeholder keys so you can see how
things can go wrong if the adversary
could somehow get hold of these keys
maybe in the future then the adversary
can start decrypting okay and this is
why the zero knowledge the security
proof holds under the assumption that so
I mean it's clearly in the paper is very
explicit that you know the general works
only if the adversary cannot corrupt
adaptively because otherwise that were
so you can see the proof and then
corrupt stakeholders keys that he needs
for so that's important
furthermore it's explicit that it's
assumed that in this blockchain nobody
will ever know on a stakeholder will
ever just keep their key even if there
is zero stake on their key
they will never release it so these are
two assumptions that they make and you
know one can think of whether this may
be even reasonable assumptions for the
about blockchain but so the point that
we were trying to make is that it's
still very dangerous to other some
shion's to the blocks to it when you say
blockchain is very dangerous to add the
assumptions in order for your general
truth to go through and in fact we show
that even if all these assumptions are
true so that version is not adaptive
estatic honest parties are very nice
they will never leak their key even in
that case because they the blockchain
exists you can show an adversary of zero
knowledge which follows the rules that
we
but it's still able to decrypt to to to
break zero knowledge how do you do that
you basically write a simple smart
contract which you can write it goes the
whole point this block chains exist
there are some smart contracts that are
run on it right and in the smart Condor
we called it explicit if they crypt for
me you can make it more subtle you
publish one ciphertext and you ask
stakeholder in in exchange of money if
the decoder can tell you what is the
message encrypted and with the specific
encryption scheme that they use you can
it's such that you can give the
randomness used for encryption so you
don't have to reveal anything about your
key you just give the message and the
randomness that is used for encryption
and then in order to check if this is a
right decryption you can just run again
the encryption function so you don't so
it's this is what the smart contact will
do and if this the values given to the
smart contacts are correct the party
gets the money
the stakeholder gets the money you know
you can see it in a zero knowledge
adversary takes the key the the proof
and then we'll just publish some some
smart contracts pay some people maybe
ten fifteen and then will decrypt enough
keys enough shares and we'll be able to
to see what was the witness encrypted in
this in this new way and just to some
observation so if you think of this you
might think well so first of all here we
are not asking be honest stakeholder to
reveal the key we are just asking to use
the key to decrypt so they are not
revealing the key so we are still
following the rules second you might
think that yeah the stake of there is
not really honest because he is
decrypting needs so an honest person
will not do that but we claim that it's
it's not necessarily clear right because
this the blockchain player is not aware
of how is key are going to be used in in
another external protocol right so I
don't know that I'm actually the
ecliptic a ciphertext which is part of a
of a proof right why it's not
like I'm maliciously trying to entrap
some on his program and similarly our
adversary is not corrupting anybody the
only thing that other mystery needs is
to be a user of the blockchain meaning
you need to have some money so that he
can pay people for this market how much
money less than definitely less than the
majority of stake and also again this is
not a bribing attack if not bribing an
honest party - because bribing assumes
that the honest party is going to become
dishonest this is doing something that
is dishonest but here there is not
dishonest it is just a smart contract
which is legitimate and I'm not breaking
any rule yes yeah you can rerun demise
it in in that case though we need to
change the smart contract because then I
then you might not be able to give me
the randomness if I rerun demise you're
not going to be it's a scheme that you
are not going to be able to tell me what
is the randomness I used to increase so
it would be unclear if the if I can
check correctness of the answer but
definitely in that case we need a little
bit more sophisticated smart contracts
well somehow I have to add some more
requirements on what it means for
earning a description to be the correct
one or maybe I mean at least this is the
cleanest I could think of of a smart
contracts but you can do something yeah
so but this is exactly the good point
which is is not necessarily the case
that I'm going to publish the crypt for
me I can be more subtle right and I can
maybe say something else the point is we
cannot rely on the fact that the
adversary would be as explicit and and
we can catch him so the observation that
we what do we derive from our attack is
which was a simple attack right it's
that we should be careful when we are
trying to build a click an external
crypto tool that uses the blockchain we
should be careful of not of how we are
using the permanent secrets on the
blockchain right because again we we
have to be careful how we use this
assumption we cannot use these secrets
because things can happen and you know
this this attack is one example
and then of course the other observation
is that now we we still don't have a
public Wi-Fi but you know it's probably
from from any boxiness oh no now it's 3
p.m. how much time do I have
so maybe five minutes okay so the next
five minutes I'm gonna I'm gonna talk
about the second contribution of this
work which is okay now let's construct a
public Wi-Fi but you don't know it from
any blocks from a generic blockchain
assumptions so I'm gonna define my
assumption you can tell me what you
think about it and then I'm gonna tell
you how I use it for publicly if I will
do it
so this is our book chain assumption
first i'm gonna assume that every block
in the blockchain contains a
distinguished field what is for a phone
ago critic a concrete example if you
think of Bitcoin every block in Bitcoin
as a coinbase transaction
what is this transaction is the it
contains the wallet of the miners who
cashes the reward that's pretty standard
I don't know it's other blockchains
also have some coin based transactions
but this is the first thing that we are
saying is that we are going to assume
that we are dealing with the blockchain
where every block has this field where
we put a string where miners put a
string now our bucket the Assumption on
the blockchain is that if you take any
sequence of n blocks and you look at
this fields you know in the sandbox at
risk
k of them will have will will have
unique values in this field at least
move more than half of them are computed
by honest parties putting some high
entropy string on this field let me give
an example with Bitcoin that hopefully
will clarify what we are saying so
basically the example that we are saying
is the assumption is that maybe take any
hundred Bitcoin blocks and look at the
coinbase transaction at least 50 of them
so this coin base is a wallet at least
the transaction will have fresh wallet
which basically means a miner will take
the money from one on a new public key
every time and of this 50 at least 26
were computed by an honest party that's
basically what we're assuming another
way to think of it is that you know
there is this distinguished field and in
this blockchain that we are envisioning
most many times honest parties will put
a fresh a hymen into B string in this
field when also if you think so I'm not
talking about a truly random string I'm
talking about how mean entropy string
you're saying the majority of the of the
of the block so this is the distinction
between honest and fair so the point is
that you cannot in Bitcoin you don't put
in the blockchain an amount of not
proportional to the worth of a person
you would weigh less so even if you have
like a you know slightly less than
majority still adverse we control the
most one-third than your okay very far
as the thing that will give you much or
anything okay so you talk about the
content that gives you majority I guess
yeah so in fact we don't claim because I
mean I used to be kind to say this is
what it will mean right will mean that
you have this wallet and mostly honest
miners will always put a fresh wallet we
didn't prove that this is satisfied by
the Bitcoin we were just putting up this
assumption and of course next step would
be to to see which what block chains
will satisfy this this assumption
the majority of this cake there must be
some inside the majority of this cake
yeah I need a majority so yeah so this I
mean as you can see there is nothing
here about the consensus we are not
assuming really anything about the
contest we are we are swimming something
that I call it uncertain they're posting
time so basically yes but I did so I
think by serious point is the even you
don't know that those team those are all
honest right the work on the bitcoin is
scheme which is some construction so I I
don't
so I specially say it I the problem that
we need this this fraction to be honest
so somehow we have to say that it's
computed by honest people and I don't
know how it will map it to be kind I
mean I haven't thought about through
that much to be honest but this is
something that definitely we will want
to do the majority of key
sorry yeah cake and it's big one case
this morning one so this is what we say
we would like to we would like to to
picture the to capture the fact that
when I post when I put a block on the
blockchain there is some uncertainty are
strings that there is a lot of uncertain
a lot with enough uncertainty of what
are the strings that harness people are
gonna play in the blockchain and because
there is honest people playing and
against the question is how many people
are mainly on this block I can expect
and that's where the Bitcoin problem is
coming up alright so I know I'm just
gonna so very quickly once you have this
assumption the next building block that
we really need is this written is
indistinguishable 'ti system which which
is based on blockchain as well which we
constructed and we show this is how it
looks it looks like you put a block then
for the challenge you wait enough blocks
and then you have a third round so
that's how basically you can use a Sigma
protocol and you turn it in and in in in
a public verifiable WI note that this is
not not interacting meaning the prover
is interactive but is interacting with
the blockchain the verifier is non
interactive so the verifier only needs
the third round and needs to see what
happened to the blockchain again because
I have no time the only property we
really need to prove is that our scheme
the previous scheme is WI even in
presence of blockchain collapse and once
you have this property and I don't know
nothing notes like when you're this
property I'm gonna just gonna
okay so maybe I'll just up on these
lights so this is our the the protocol
works and these are all commitments and
the DD key at the key idea is that even
if later all blockchain players are
corrupted I still this block these
commitments are still secure because
these are no encryption I'm just
commitment and the WI property of
forward security in presence of
blockchain collapse also make sure that
the composition is secure
[Applause]
exactly so you have to write down the
definition that's that's exactly what we
did like the blockchain I think what
will be a nice but you cannot do
it depends mission I think maybe what
were and I agree with you so what would
be very clear and to say that the only
property you are going to use if there
is a property no blockchains of this
perpetual chain quality or consistently
you know if there is a blockchain that
satisfy those property then needs exists
that will be much cleaner than now I
don't know I could extract more yeah we
need this property in some sense and I
extract but some probability yeah
definitely
but I think he was talking about the
case doctrine exists then myths cases
that's what it exactly and then we know
that
thank you thank you
[Applause]